- Okay, ready guys, audition him.
- It's a lot of pressure here.
(laughter)
- My name is Nick Barili
and I'm traveling the country to sit down
with some of the biggest Latinx artists
in places that have meaning to them,
and help tell their stories.
It brings a sense of emotion
because you're standing
there looking at kids
and go my God, these kids
are so communicative.
and they all have their stories.
There was nothing natural
about me playing baseball.
about me being a rock and roll singer,
there was nothing natural
about me being an actor.
Natural is just years and
year and years of hard work,
make you a natural.
- You've been a strong
advocate for representation
for a long time.
- Trying to understand your culture
and the roots that make
you the tree that you are,
and the human being that you are,
makes everybody stronger.
success is having lived your life
doing what you really want it to do.
The strongest advice I can
give is don’t stop.
Just don't stop.